bonjour david alors comment s'est passée
cette commémoration
et bien après à l'hommage place à la
contestation les milliers de
manifestants qui étaient à présent place
du canada sont partis de cette place de
ce mémorial en hommage d un million cinq
cent mille arméniens a tués lors du
génocide en 1915 par l'empiré ottoman
pour se rendre jusqu'à place a vu
trocadéro afin de réclamer la justice
pour le peuple arménien car vous l'aurez
compris l'objectif était évidemment de
se souvenir de ses victimes mais
également rappelé que la récidive est
possible en référence notamment au
dernier conflit y ait dans le
haut-karabagh une défaite militaire qui
a laissé beaucoup de traces est vécue
comme une véritable humiliation
nationale pour la plupart des arméniens
et des franco arménien qui dénonce les
actions du président turquie et du
président azerbaïdjanais est la plupart
des réseaux officiels présents lors de
cette commémoration
depuis son 16e anniversaire du génocide
arménien de 1915 ont insisté sur le fait
que la situation est extrêmement tendue
dans cette région caucasienne c'est le
cas de valérie pécresse la région la
présidente de la région ile de france la
région a fait une aide spéciale
humanitaire pour tous les réfugiés du
haut karabagh qui ont subi sept 7 cette
guerre est bien évidemment le caucase
est aujourd'hui inflammable et donc
l'indépendance de l'arménie est fragile
et il faut en permanence la soutenir
parce que là encore il faut savoir que
l'arménie
c'est notre allié ça l'a toujours été et
alors même que la france est aujourd'hui
en deuil et à nouveau par le terrorisme
il faut savoir toujours protéger nos
amis
valérie pécresse qui faisait partie des
nombreux officiels venus leur rendre
hommage à ces victimes du génocide
arménien parmi elles la maire de paris
anne hidalgo bien encore le porte parole
du
gouvernement gabriela talent et qu'ils
ont prononcés à des aides discours où
ils ont rappelé que le devoir de mémoire
était un primordial surtout en cette
période assez terne le faire également
que les manuels macron se soit rendu ce
matin sur ce mémorial un symbole
important pour aller franco arménien
mais pour eux ce n'est pas suffisant la
france aurait dû réagir agir lors du
dernier conflit dans le haut-karabagh en
novembre dernier coûte et enfin on voit
bien que là il ya une volonté de se
débarrasser de cet état chrétien qui
demandent rien à personne que d'être là
et de préserver sa culture et donc on
aurait apprécié quand même un geste plus
fort de l'occident chrétien qui se dit
chrétien et à france en particulier donc
on est un peu déçu quand même de bon le
geste les gerbes les belles paroles
c'est bien mais face aux drones aux
missiles et au char c'est un peu court
clairement aujourd'hui donc ce qu'on
espère c'est que la france au travers du
groupe de minsk s'impliquent aujourd'hui
davantage pour que le haut karabagh sur
un territoire arménien qui est
aujourd'hui une démocratie avec un
président de la république et que les
terres soient restitués à l'arménien en
tant que tel donc si on est là c'est
parce que effectivement il ya un
génocide en 1915 qui s'est poursuivie
jusqu'en 1920 23 mais on est là parce
que ce jeu de sites se poursuit
aujourd'hui
parce que la négation d'un génocide
c'est la poursuite d'un génocide
vous l'aurez compris le devoir de
mémoire est primordial pour cette
journée du 24 avril pour les franco
arménien à présent ici et mais le fait
est que rappeler surtout que le jaune
acide continue pour eux en tout cas pour
les pour les arméniens présents ici et
qu'il faut éviter à tout prix qu'il
récidive et empêcher les présidents
azerbaïdjanais et un turc d'exercer à
cette pression sur l'arménie a en tout
cas pour le moment le cortège se dirigea
vers la place du trône du trocadéro
encadrés par un important dispositif de
sécurité aucun un débordement à signaler
pour rappel également grande fierté pour
la plupart des franco arménien ici à joe
biden devrait être le pré le premier
président américain à reconnaître le
génocide arménien à merci à d'amina pour
toutes ces précisions